y
vale
y este día hemos tenido la oportunidad
de disfrutar de grandes conferencias
pero sobre todo de grandes discursos de
vida hemos tenido la oportunidad de
emocionarnos de vibrar de sentir de
soñar de reflexionar pero sobre todo de
cuestionarnos y creerme que es un gran
reto tener la oportunidad de clausurar
esta serie de conferencias en un tema
tan pero tan complejo como lo es el
discurso de la vida y quiero decirles
que precisamente este discurso de la
vida arranca de esta manera
allí en la obscuridad del universo en la
magia del planeta tierra y precisamente
en el territorio más soso que hay en
este mundo méxico hay un estado y ese
estado alberga una comunidad que se
llama lagos de moreno jalisco un
municipio y precisamente ahí allí
arranca este discurso y es que este
discurso arranca precisamente en el año
de 1995 un año en el que había cerca de
5 mil millones de habitantes de acuerdo
a las cifras del banco mundial un año en
el que disfrutábamos de la creatividad
del hombre a partir del ingenio de bill
gates y su microsoft windows 95 un año
en el que nos emocionábamos con 'toy
story' y nos dábamos cuenta que podíamos
llegar al infinito y más allá un año en
el que escucharíamos por última vez a
selena quintanilla y a sus increíbles
cumbres
un año
un día
en el que un discurso más vio la luz
precisamente el 22 de abril de 1995 un
día de la tierra para ser exactos
nació un discurso pero no fue hasta
precisamente diez años después que
entendió que ese discurso no solamente
la palabra sino que también podía
transformarse en un mensaje de cambio de
transformación en un mensaje que podía
darle la vuelta al mundo y es que
precisamente hablar del discurso es un
tema sumamente complejo
entonces le quiero pedir ayuda al mejor
amigo con el que todos contamos y es
precisamente el buscador más potente del
mundo entonces al buscar qué es un
discurso nos vamos a dar cuenta que
existen cerca de 111 millones de
entradas relacionadas con esta palabra
pero para fines prácticos de esta charla
me voy a situar en la cuarta acepción
que da la real academia de la lengua
española y es que precisamente un
discurso es una serie de palabras
empleadas para manifestar emociones
pensamientos cree
sensación es un discurso al final del
día es un retrato y una imagen fiel de
lo que somos
entonces por qué es que yo me atrevo a
decir que la vida es un discurso yo creo
que la mejor persona que podría
sintetizar está afirmación es un
mexicano universal como octavio paz
y es que octavio paz- precisa en el arco
y la lira que todos y cada uno de los
aquí presentes estamos hechos de
palabras
que todos y cada uno de los aquí
presentes somos un discurso andante
que todos los que tenemos la dicha de
seguir respirando esta noche somos un
mensaje
y precisamente al hablar de esta
cuestión cabría preguntarse entonces
pues bueno cuál es el nexo causal entre
el discurso y la vida y es que
precisamente la vida y el discurso son
prácticamente lo mismo
ambos discurso y vida tienen un origen
una concepción una génesis
ambos discurso y vida deben
desarrollarse deben de fortalecerse
deben de sentirse ambos discurso y vida
llega un momento en el que tienen que
reproducirse
y también ambos llega un momento en el
que deben de extinguirse de apagarse
y precisamente es en este momento donde
yo quisiera pedirles un favor
quisiera pedirles que durante un lapso
no mayor a 20 segundos me ayudaran
cerrando sus ojos
y que se imaginarán que hay siete mil
millones de personas en este mundo que
están dispuestos a escucharlos que no
hay barreras del lenguaje que no hay
barreras religiosas que no hay barreras
étnicas ni mucho menos geográficas hoy
siete mil millones de personas están
dispuestas a escucharlos les pido que
abran sus ojos por favor
cuál sería la pregunta subyacente que le
diríamos a esos 7.000 millones de
personas
definitivamente hoy hoy yo los invitaría
a reflexionar una pregunta importante
están listos para que el discurso de su
vida acabe esta noche
están listos para cerrar los ojos de
manera eterna
están listos para despedirse
están listos
para poder
sub sumar su vida su discurso o por el
contrario ya dijeron lo que tenían que
decir
y se han quedado con las ganas de hacer
porque a lo largo de más de 13 años
hablando frente a un público con cursos
experiencias estados países he llegado a
una conclusión
que todas las personas perdemos
oportunidades por no saber qué decir
y precisamente he concluido que en el
discurso de la vida
su discurso el discurso de su vida
debemos de entender que este es efímero
que es corto que es breve y que en ese
discurso de la vida al final del día hay
tres cosas que no van a regresar
la palabra dada
la flecha lanzada y la oportunidad
perdida
porque al final del día nuestras
palabras una espada y un escudo nuestras
palabras pueden crear galaxias o pueden
destruir las nuestras palabras pueden
ser dulzura o pueden ser el más cruel de
los venenos nuestras palabras son como
una flecha que impacta en los
pensamientos y en las en los corazones
pero esa flecha puede causar amor o
puede causar dolor y al final del día
nuestras palabras son una única y
grandiosa oportunidad
para poder sembrar una semilla de
esperanza de cambio de paz
pero hay algo muy importante que también
me han enseñado las palabras y que me ha
enseñado el discurso de la vida
y es que precisamente
el tiempo
el tiempo de su discurso de vida
comienza a agotarse
el tiempo de su discurso de vida nos
llega a enseñar
[Música]
que se baja
que es fugaz
y que a partir de esta experiencia de
vida de este discurso hoy podemos
entender que no importa si nos gusta los
maratones la ciencia la mercadotecnia la
psicología la tecnología no importa cada
discurso de todos y cada uno de ustedes
es genial por el simple hecho de serlo
y hoy he descubierto que el discurso de
mi vida se puede resumir en cuatro
aspectos importantes en amar
en perdonar
en vivir y en dejar vivir
porque precisamente hoy quiero traer con
ustedes una reflexión que me encanta y
que hace mucho tiempo me enseñó mi padre
y es que vamos a imaginarnos que en este
discurso de la vida nos encontramos una
jungla y si nos preguntamos quién es el
regente de esta jungla o el líder de la
jungla inmediatamente pensaríamos en el
león
y precisamente un día en esa jungla
donde reina del león
experimentamos el más grande de los
incendios y nos damos cuenta que es tan
abrasivo que todas las especies
comienzan a retirarse y pensaríamos que
el más fuerte el líder se quedaría y les
tengo una noticia es el primero en huir
y al final de que este rey se va
solamente quedan dos especies
las llenas y un pequeño colibrí
y precisamente las llenas nos enseñan
las películas o los libros son
sarcásticas son agrias honduras son
burlescas
y las llenas observan de manera detenida
como el colibrí volaba y aleteaba de
manera increíble para ir a un pequeño
riachuelo a absorber diminutas gotas de
agua y tratar de irlas a depositar al
fuego y las llenas se reían y le decían
hummer colibrí 3 un tonto que no se ha
entendido que te vas a incinerar que te
vas a morir y el colibrí contestó
es muy probablemente que lo haga es muy
probablemente que sea un tonto que sea
un romántico que sea un idealista pero
hoy simple y sencillamente estoy
haciendo lo que me corresponde
y esto
esto nos lleva
a una penúltima pregunta
después de haber escuchado a grandes
hombres y mujeres que me han antecedido
en el uso de la palabra que se van a
llevar de esta charla cuál va a ser el
discurso de su vida
y es que precisamente
en el mundo a la fecha hay más de siete
mil millones de discursos unos más
grandes otros más pequeños
uno es muy rimbombantes y otros muy
escuetos pero al final del día todos
esos discursos de vida son trascendentes
y son importantes
hoy todos los aquí presentes tienen una
gran oportunidad única e irrepetible la
oportunidad de llevar el discurso de su
vida hacia donde lo quieran llevar no
importa si lo rayaron si se equivocaron
si fallaron si quieren cambiar porque el
momento oportuno y preciso para poder
hacerlo es el día de hoy no es mañana
porque al final del día en ese mundo
donde habitan siete mil millones de
discursos no hay contratos seguros
hoy
todos los aquí presentes tuvimos la
dicha de amanecer pero no tenemos la
certeza de anochecer
por eso hoy simple y sencillamente yo
les quiero decir gracias mil gracias por
estar aquí por acompañarnos por
escucharnos por reirse junto con
nosotros hoy hoy los invito a que sean
ustedes el mejor el mejor el mejor
discurso de su vida muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]